l'alarme est prévenu qu'il
faudra augmenter la.
- On ne pourra jamais être
vraiment prêt à affronter
une catastrophe naturelle de
l'ampleur de celle qui afflige
la Colombie-Britane.e.e.
Une fois tous les 100 ans,
dit-on, et encore...
Mais avec les changements
climatiques, il faut s'attendre
à ce qu'elles soient de plus
en plus fréqeseses, extrêmes,
imprévisibles.
Le Canada doit faire face un peu
partout à des feux de forêt.
Ici, on a connu une fameuse
te d d d de verglas, mais le
risque qui domine généralement,
c'est ce qu'on voit dans l'ouest
et qu'on a vu en 1996 au
Saguenay : les inondations.
JULIEN BOURQUEititititut
canadien pour choix climatiques
- C'est beaucoup les inondations
au niveau fédéral les trois
quarts des financements après
désastres vevevevernement
fédéral argent donné aux
provinces provient des
inondations.
- Le gouvernement fédéral
a confié à l'Institut canadien
pour des choix climatiques
le soin de recenser les risques
accrus pour les infrastructures
et les citoyens qui y vivent
en fonction du réchauffement
de la planète. Une fois passée
l'urgence en Colombie-
Britannique, la recommandation
est de passer au diagnostic en
mettant à jour la cartographie
des risques.
- Au Canada, en ce moment,
les cartes de zones inondables
sont désuètes, elles datent
des années 70-80 et elles ne
tiennent absolumcococococompte
des changements climatiques.
Première chose à faire, au
fédéral : travailler. Je sais
que c'est en train de se faire
pour que cette info-là soit
utile et disponible pour
la prise de décision.
- Une cartographie, c'est
ce qu'a fait la Communauté
métropolitaine de Montréal après
les inondations catastrophiques
de 2017 sur les rives
du lac des Deux-Montagnes.
MAONONONONONONI, dg, Communauté
métropolitaine de Montréal
- Nos cartes dataient des années
70, elles étaient faites
différemment d'une ville àe,e,ee
méthodologie et on a convenu
collectivement qu'on devait
se doter d'un plan archipel
inondations. Donc il y avait làr
un territoire, il faut bien
le connaître et ça passe par
des bonnes cartes.
Po i i i i i i il a fallu faire
ce qu'on appelle un relevé
Lidar. Un relevé Lidar, c'estsca
scanner le territoire complet
et nous donner la topographie
au centimètre près.
- Résultat : en 2019, la ville
de Deux-Montagnes, durement
touchée deux ans plus tôt, reste
les pieds au sec parce qu'elle
participe au projet pilote de
la CMM alors que sa voisine,
Sainte-Marthe-sur-le-Lac,
est aux prises avec la même
catastrophe qu'en 2017.
- C'est un cocktail de m
qui est proposé, on comprend,
là, oui, il y a la digue, oui,
il y a le "water square", oui,
il y a d'autres mesures qui vont
nous permettre de capter l'eau.
- Résultat : fin 2021, Sainte-
Marthe-sur-le-Lac est elle aussi
protégée par de nouvelles digues
réhaussées, comme ses voisines.
Un projet modèle?
- Modèle? Oui, au niveau local,
d'autres a a a a a a a au Canada
ont créé leurs propres cartes
d'inondations, certainement
le point de départ pour prendre
les bonnes décisions.
Les municipalités sont
responsables d'environ 60 %
des infrastructures au Canada,
mais elles n'ont pas
nécessairement les fonds
pour réagir, donc 10 cents
pour chaque dollar.
- Reste les routes, les ponts,
les voies de chemin de fer :
tous les secteurs de la société
et les gouvernements doivent
revoir leuvevevevevevevevevestir
lourdement.
- C'est clair, c'est
des milliards de dollars.
Si les gouvernements
ne s é é é é é é é é élaborer
des politiques pour déjà donner
l'information, pour savoir
où le risque se trouve
par rapport aux inondations,ppps
infrastructures sont à risques,
ça va coûter très cher
aux Canadiens.
- La sortie de COVID est
un bon moment pour investirelel,
en sachant que réparer les pots
cassés après le désastre coûtera
toujours plus cher.
Sainte-Marthe-sur-le-Lac
en porte encore les cicatrices
et subit les foudres de ceux qui
ont perdu leur vue sur le lac
à cause de la digue, mais
c'est au nom du bien commun.
Jean-Michel Leprince,
Radio-Canada, Montréa